some of the best comedians around are
gathering here in austin from april 13th
to the 24th it's the moon tower just for
last comedy festival featuring many
different comedians and we are going to
speak with mark norman who is a
headliner for the event good morning
mark how are you
hey good to be here great eyebrows oh
thank you so
where are you at right now you're not in
austin yet but you're coming down here
i was actually just there i did a
podcast and a couple shows but now i'm
in indianapolis indiana
that's literally where i'm from so whoa
get out of here go cold
go colts and we're excited to have you
here down in austin kind of tell me a
little bit about you know what you're
looking forward to i know you're going
to be down here on april 20th i believe
that's when you're performing
you got it sister i'll be at the
paramount uh theater and
i've played there before great room i
did it during covid so it was half full
so i'm excited to fill that thing up and
uh have a hell of a show that's awesome
and kind of tell me a little bit about
you know how you plan your acts
well i write a bunch of
horrific jokes and hopefully people like
them and then i tour it all over the
country and then when i get to a big
show like the paramount i really try to
bring the heat and kill it and it's nice
because i do clubs and they have a check
spot and chicken wings and hecklers
so theaters are nice because there's
none of that and it's just it's just a
nice fun night of comedy you're only
performing is it one night or you're
doing several nights
just one night in and out i love moon
tower i've done it many years and i'm
excited to come back what are you
looking forward to this year at moon
tower
well austin's got great crowds uh i feel
like i'm i've built a bond with them
over the years and i got new material
and plus it's a bunch of great comics
who get to hang out and go to after
parties so i'm excited it's gonna be a
hoot so yeah it's gonna be different
this year because covert restrictions
are a little eased is all right
oh yeah you got that right i mean i
always say uh wearing a
mask in in a texas is like wearing a
helmet at the skate park you know you
got to weigh your away your priorities
what's more important my health are
being called
so
i can't wait to get back down there your
governor's in a wheelchair you got great
tacos
i'm pumped marknormancomedy.com
look for the paramount theater listing
and click on the button and we'll hook
you up folks
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with me and is there anything else
that you want to add maybe that i didn't
ask
uh
no i think you got it um praise allah
thanks for having me i'll see you all in
hell comedy
the moon tower just for laughs festival
austin starts april 13th and runs until
april 24th you can see mark for one
night only on april 20 at the paramount
theater